Today, we're going to just start
by talking about what glass is
and what its properties are.
But before we do, this came in--
we've been talking
about defects, OK.
And vacancies, point defects,
and then on Wednesday,
we did line defects.
Remember those?
Right, and they create
these planes that come in.
They're slip planes
that allow atoms
to slide across each other that
allows you to plasticly deform
a material.
And so OK, but with regards to
vacancies, I got this by email.
I'm at the Heathrow
Airport in London,
and even this aerial sculpture
has vacancy point defects
in its pattern.
Look at that.
There you go.
And there you go.
This is a beautiful
thing, right?
Thank you, Sophia.
And notice that she's looking
at it with her periodic table,
of course, right.
That's a no-brainer.
But even such structures
can't escape the fact
that you always have vacancies.
That was cool.
OK, now where were we?
Right, so we're going
to talk about glass.
Now, this is glass,
and I'll start
with just how cool glass is.
But this is also not just--
this isn't all that glass is.
And I want to make
sure we get that
by the end of this lecture.
This is not the only
thing that glass means.
But this is what we think of.
So here's a really cool video.
OK.
No and yes.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
There they are.
Look at that molten
[INAUDIBLE] and it's--
oh, he just added something.
We'll talk about that.
Oh, and now he's mixing it.
- Table man carefully mixes
this glass [INAUDIBLE]..
Once the glass is blended
to his specifications--
OK, there it is.
Is it a liquid?
Is it a solid?
- [INAUDIBLE]
And then he just puts it
through a little roller.
- That will mash that
glass flat [INAUDIBLE]
Mash it flat, and there
is your piece of glass.
OK, and we'll see another one.
I'll show you another
video of a larger scale--
don't keep going.
[END PLAYBACK]
OK.
So what was it that
they were just mixing?
Why does it have the
properties that it has?
Why can they just
take this thing
that's not really
liquid and not really
solid, it's some viscous
thing, and roll it through,
and then it comes into
this really beautiful sheet
that we all call glass?
And it all has to do with
what I showed you before,
and what we've
been talking about,
which is order or disorder.
And so we did this already.
We covered, OK, a solid that
which is dimensionally stable.
That's cool.
Classification, oh ordered,
regular, long-range order, BCC,
FCC.
All right.
OK, long-range.
Remember, we said it just keeps
going and going and going.
And then we say, well, it
may be once in a while,
once every 1,000, 10,000,
100,000, there's a vacancy.
OK, so we started
messing with it.
But it still had this long
range-- gesundheit-- order.
And so they were
called crystalline,
crystalline with defects,
maybe, but still crystalline.
That is not what glass is.
Glass is disordered.
And so that is the topic of
today and next Wednesday.
What happens when you go
from an ordered structure,
like this, oh maybe
it's got some--
oh these are 2D defects,
right, the whole things
are kind of-- so it's
poly crystalline,
but it's still kind
of crystalline,
and it's very ordered,
to totally disordered.
All right.
And so a disordered solid
looks random, certainly
over long range.
There might be
short range order.
There might be some short range
order, but over a long range,
it's going to be disordered.
It's going to look random.
This is called amorphous
as opposed to crystalline.
This is also called glass.
So one of the first things we've
got, this is really important,
glass is not just the window,
or the thing on your phone
that keeps cracking.
No.
Glass is equal to
an amorphous solid.
Well, so it's bigger.
It's broader.
It's bolder.
You can have glass
metal, metallic glass.
It's a thing.
Any solid that doesn't have long
range order that's amorphous
is a glass.
OK.
Now in this class we
will use SiO2 as--
so what we're going
to do is we're
going to talk about
glass with an example.
We will use the
kind that winds up
being in the
windshield of your car
or in the window of your
house and on your phone.
And that is called quartz.
So the chemistry
that we're going
to use is quartz, or
SiO2 OK, and what we're
going to talk about is
how processing effects
that chemistry, affects the--
sorry, the solid that forms.
So processing.
And there is lots of
processing parameters
and we can talk about.
What I want to focus on
today is the cooling,
the cooling rate in particular.
So that's going to
be the focus today.
We'll talk about the chemistry.
We'll talk about the processing.
And we'll talk
about how those go
back and forth to create glass.
Now, OK, what am
I starting with?
I'm starting with a crystal.
This is quartz.
This is how you see quartz.
Now, quartz is this
beautiful, beautiful crystal.
And it is ordered.
That's why I'm saying
the word crystal.
I'm not saying the word glass.
All right.
This is an ordered solid.
It's not cubic.
So it's not one of the
ones we've learned.
But it's still
periodically repeating.
All right.
And so it's a crystal.
It's got long range order.
It's called quartz.
It's SiO2 So I'm
going to hand this out
so you can just see it.
And that's what I want to
start, I want to talk about,
is that crystal,
OK, because that's
what we're going to be messing
up and creating short-range.
We're going to go from
long-range to short-range.
OK, so what is it?
Well, let's see.
In this class, how do we
think about chemistry?
Well you can think about
it now in different ways.
Let's pick Lewis.
All right, OK.
So I say, OK, I got
silicon, silicon, silicon,
if I think about
silicon as it's Lewis,
you know, dots,
then it's got four.
It's got four valence
electrons ready to bond.
You can see that now if I
have oxygen, what does oxygen
look like?
So oxygen has six.
I'm going to put
those like that.
So oxygen has six.
Maybe it's got a
couple lone pairs,
which has six valence
electrons, not four.
Now so if I had--
so when you look at this,
you think, you know,
silicon looks like it wants
four bonds when you look at it.
And in fact, we know that
the crystal in silicon
as we've talked
about-- gesundheit--
is tetrahedral because of this.
Right, it's tetrahedral.
Remember, it's a two atom
basis FCC lattice which is
is diamond.
But what if I just
look at it with oxygen,
come at this with oxygen
and say, well, you know,
I want to have four bonds.
One way to do that would
be to add four oxygens.
So what if I did this?
What if I did
silicon and oxygen,
and I did plus 4
times the oxygen.
Well, then you could
see, what could you do?
You could do this, OK, and
this and this and this.
But now, OK, the oxygens,
how would they be left?
They'd be left like this.
And you'll see why I'm focusing
on this SiO4 group in a minute.
That's what I got.
Now, OK, if I go back in
and I put my Lewis cap on,
silicon is very happy
it's obeying octet,
but the oxygens
aren't quite there.
So they need one more
electron, one more electron.
I'm going to make it a little
bolder because I've added it.
All right.
So I've added an electron
to each of those.
So if I had SiO4,
and I added 4--
if I had SiO4, and I added
four electrons to it,
I get a really nice
stable Lewis structure.
Right.
That's called a silicate.
That's a silicate group.
SiO4.
And I need those four
electrons, as you
can see just from looking
at the simple dot diagram.
I need those four
electrons to make it happy.
OK.
By the way, just
speaking of naming, OK,
so let's see silicate,
right silica, SiO2,
we can talk about, so what we do
is when we have oxide, silicon
oxide, just in terms
of naming, you know,
like if you have an oxide,
often, you kind of add an a,
right, so like silicon went
from SiO2, we call it silica.
So in Al2O3, let's see, Al2O3
is also an oxide, right?
And so we called that--
this is something
we've already done, alumina.
All right, and so on,
except for sometimes.
And so sometimes,
like for example,
if you do calcium oxide,
well, that's called lime.
It's called lime, calcium oxide.
Well, what about sodium?
Well, sodium, if you
do sodium, you're
going to need it I'm
assuming the oxygen might
break off and become to--
so you've got to think
about the charge again.
So Na20 would be the
one that works there.
All right, and this
is sodium oxide.
But see, sodium
oxide, but sometimes,
it's called soda, because--
and this is an extra step,
because soda comes from calcium
from--
let's see, Na2O from--
how do you make it?
You make it from Na2CO3, which
is actually what is soda?
Sodium carbonate.
But because we make Na2O,
that oxide from something
that we call soda, sometimes
people just call in Na2O soda,
it's not.
But sometimes you see that.
So I just want to kind of make
you aware some of these names.
Why am I writing it there?
We're coming back to that.
We're going to use those later.
That's partly why I want
them to be on the board,
and also tell you
about the names.
So Na2O is sodium oxide.
But it's made from sodium
carbonate, which is soda.
OK.
All right.
Now, OK, now, here's the thing.
That's an isolated molecule.
Look at what I'm
passing around here.
Oh, I wanted to tell
you about the window.
I almost forgot.
In this class, in
this class, we don't
go around saying that windows
are thicker on the bottom,
than on the top, because
glass flows like a liquid.
No.
That is not true.
That may be true
down the street.
That is not true here.
We do the calculation.
Glass is not a liquid, not once
it's cooled down into a solid.
It's a solid.
If you do the calculation,
and it's a centimeter thick,
a window pane, for
that piece of glass,
under normal diffusion
and temperature conditions
for that piece of
glass at the bottom
to become thicker
by one nanometer
would take 10 billion years.
OK.
So no, it's not flowing under
its own weight in a window.
What happened?
What happened is
people didn't know
how to make glass
uniformly way back when,
and so they came out
un-uniform, non uniform.
What's easier?
To install it with
the heavier side
up or the heavier side down?
It's easier to install it if
it's heavier on the bottom.
Class doesn't flow.
OK.
All right.
I wanted to get that done early.
Yeah.
Oh, here we go.
OK, so this is quartz.
This is crystalline silica.
This is groups of
SiO2, not SiO4.
This was how we made
a molecule happy.
But watch what happens now when
I go from that picture to SiO2.
So now, I've got these--
let's suppose I've got these
molecules of-- and I'm just
going to not draw it 3D, but
I'm going to draw it 2D, and OK,
there's--
gesundheit-- there's
all these charges there.
So now these are
these molecules,
these silicate groups.
And they're kind of happy,
and they're on their own.
But now look what happens here.
See, those two oxygen, what
if instead of each of these
being separate,
they came together?
All right.
Well, you can see that--
you see, if they shared
the same oxygen here,
if they shared the
same oxygen here,
then that oxygen is
actually now Lewis
happy without the extra charge.
So this oxygen,
this bridge, oxygen,
doesn't need that extra
electron to be happy.
What does to be happy mean?
Well, we know what that means.
And if we're talking about Lewis
and speaking in those terms,
it means you've got your octet.
All right.
So now the bridge oxygen--
oh, but that is what
I'm passing around.
That is what quartz is.
It's all the oxygen is
happy without needing
the extra charge, because
they are all bridged.
So that's what we've done.
We've made silica
by thinking about it
in terms of these
silicate groups, OK,
and just bridging
them all together.
And I can't draw it.
But you have it
there, and 3D models
are the easiest way to see it.
And they all act as bridges
between silicate groups.
OK.
So why am I--
why do I keep this
silicate group?
So a lot of times if you
look up the structure,
and this is the
3D structure, you
see every single
oxygen is a bridge.
Every single oxygen is a bridge.
And it's nice to think
about it in terms
of the silicate groups.
Why?
Why did I start with that?
I started with that because
these groups are very strong.
They stay together.
And they kind of act as
building blocks for the glass
and for the quartz.
And you now know those
are two different things,
quartz is silicate groups
ordered in a crystal.
Glass is what we're
going to get to.
It's when they're disordered.
OK.
And why is that?
Well, because these oxygen, you
see the silica, the tetrahedron
with the silicon atom and
those oxygens is pretty robust.
But the bond between
the oxygens is-- well,
there's a whole lot of
rotation that can happen here.
You see that?
That thing can rotate around.
So that's a good
way to picture this.
That's a good way
to picture quartz
is these silicate groups
that are bonded together
through these bridge
oxygens, but they
have a lot of rotational
and distortion
relative one with respect to
one another, that is possible.
So I take those
silicate groups, OK.
Here they are up top, and
I bring them together,
and I make a perfect crystal.
That is what's
being passed around.
But look, because there's
so much possibility
for rotation and distortion,
maybe that didn't happen.
Maybe as they start to form
or they find each other,
and they start bridging, maybe
they didn't quite make it.
And you can imagine these
things are kind of bulky groups
coming together and
twisting around.
You missed the mark, it
might be hard to get back.
So how does one
happen over the other?
All right, that's the crystal.
That's the not
crystal, the glass.
And it depends on
a couple of things.
And that's what I want
to talk about next.
It depends on the
temperature and the cooling.
Depends on the temperature
and the cooling.
So how does temperature come in?
So temperature comes
in because temperature
makes everything vibrate.
Right.
It gives these atoms and
these groups kinetic energy.
OK.
So let's look at that.
So if we were to plot,
for example, temperature
versus the volume
per mole, so this is,
you know, for a given number
of these atoms, much volume
do they take?
Well, you can imagine that
that is actually related
to how much energy they have.
All right.
So like if I had like
a crystal, you know,
maybe I'll start it here.
And if I have a
crystal, you know,
and I increase the
temperature a little bit,
maybe they're
going to move more.
And as they move more,
they need more room.
And this is just a
simple-- you can just
think of like a
simple atom, connected
to another on a spring.
And more kinetic energy, more
temperature, it goes further.
And now you're all thinking,
well, wait a second,
doesn't it go in as
far as it goes out?
Why?
Does it need more volume?
Well, that is because of what
we have already talked about,
which is this energy curve
between two atoms, or two
silicate groups.
This potential energy
curve that plots
the energy between
those two groups
and, say, the
distance between them,
has something very
important about it,
has something very important.
This is the spring.
OK, so I'm in there, and
I'm at T equals 0 here.
That would be like T equals 0.
The absolute ground
state, the place
where everything is just
in its minimum energy,
but now I start
making things move.
All right, I put
kinetic energy into it,
I increase the
temperature, what happens?
The energy goes up.
But look, it doesn't go up.
It goes like this.
The average-- I'm a little
bit higher in energy,
right, I'm a little
bit higher in energy.
So where I am is
there, on average.
Now I'm a little bit higher
in energy, and so where I am
is there, and now I'm a little
bit higher, and where I am
is there.
This is what happens
to the average.
That's why solids expand.
It's because of the asymmetry
in this potential energy
curve, which we have
already talked about.
It's because of the asymmetry.
You see.
This is going out differently
than this goes up.
That's why you have
thermal expansion.
All right.
Things are vibrating.
But more often than not, they're
going to be farther apart.
And so this happens.
So we've just understood
this from an atomic--
so this would be like
if I had a crystal,
and I'm going to save three
letters and write xtal.
That's so efficient.
And then I keep going.
And by the way,
the slope of this
is called slope is called the
thermal expansion coefficient.
Thermal expansion.
That is the definition of the
thermal expansion coefficient.
Sometimes we use alpha.
That's the slope of this line.
It's the volume per
mole divided by--
over the temperature,
the change in the volume
or the change in temperature.
It's the thermal expansion
coefficient of the material.
OK, so I'm adding
temperature, and I'm expanding
and I'm expanding and
then I get to this point.
I get to this point.
This point here is where
everything changes.
Everything changes.
That's the melting
point of the solid.
That's the melting point.
Now at the melting
point, as we know,
the whole thing goes
through a transition.
It goes through a
phase transition.
And it becomes a liquid.
And the thermal
expansion of the liquid
is different than the
solid, because those, now,
you think about those
molecules are not rigidly
bonded to each other anymore.
They're more weakly bonded,
and they're moving around
with a lot of kinetic energy.
And so when they get
more kinetic energy,
they can expand even more.
That's why those
slopes are different.
But as we know, there's
also a big volume change.
There's a sudden volume change.
In going from a
solid to a liquid,
there's a sudden volume change.
And it would be the same thing
if I went back the other way.
Right, I'm cooling it
down and cooling it down,
and all of a sudden, I get to
the solidification temperature
of the material, and
I become a crystal.
Except when I don't.
And when I don't, that's
when I become a glass.
And that's what we
have to talk about now
is, how do we go from this
very simple picture of being
a glass--
being a liquid or being a
solid, a crystalline solid,
how do we go from
that to being a glass?
And to explain this,
to start, I want
to show you something
really cool that can happen.
That actually wasn't
an intentional pun.
But it has to do with
cooling, and it's really cool,
because sometimes, if
you cool a liquid down,
it doesn't solidify right there.
Then that's called
super cooling.
So you can actually cool
the liquid down like that,
and have it stay a liquid.
That's called super cooling.
By the way, so this is
called super cooling.
By the way, you can
do that with water.
And so I want to show you
like one of the coolest things
you could do tonight.
It's a Friday night.
You're going to
have guests over,
or you'll be out at that
same restaurant that
knows about you,
because you asked them
already all about the
candle and the oxygen.
And you always come with
your periodic table,
and this time, you sit down
and you say I don't want water.
Do you want
sparkling or regular?
I want super cooled.
This is what you're
going to get.
This is what they'll bring you.
They should.
If it's a good restaurant, this
is what they would bring you.
You know, so here's who is
supercooled water being poured.
This is what you should
see in your glass.
Now, that is a liquid
that is stable, for now,
below its melting point, below
its solidification point.
So what happens is as
soon as it hits the glass,
it's like, whoa, wait a second,
I am supposed to be a crystal,
and it immediately solidifies.
All right, so it
immediately went like this.
Now, by the way, it's not that
hard to make supercooled water.
If anybody's interested, I'd be
happy to tell you how to do it.
You can't just put
bottles in a freezer.
That won't work.
But it's not that hard to do.
Now, OK, back and
forth, melting point,
supercooled-- oh,
it's playing again.
And it starts freezing.
You can also take a bottle
of supercooled water
and just go like this.
It's liquid inside
and just tap it,
and the whole thing
freezes instantly.
It's really cool.
OK.
Now, why am I
talking about this?
Because you can super
cool and go down.
You could go below
that transition point
and go and go down,
like I just did there
and become a crystal right
away, but you could also not.
You could also become a solid,
so you could become a crystal,
or you could also
become a solid.
And I'm going to need
another plot to do this.
And you could become a
solid right where you were.
You might not go down
to the crystal curve,
but you might start a new curve.
And that will be a glass.
And so we're going to draw this
again and show you a glass,
but this is what we need is
this framework to understand
when a glass forms.
So this was our picture,
crystalline, crystalline,
glass, amorphous equals glass.
When does it form?
Now I think the best--
I'll show you that
one in a second.
I think the best way
to think about it
is let's draw the
plot again, and I
think the best way
to think about it
is an analogy that has been
used before, and let's see--
and this is temperature.
This is volume per mole.
By the way, that could
be energy, or enthalpy.
Yeah, because as the atoms
aren't packed in as well,
we know this, right, as
they're not packed in as well,
they're also going to
be higher in energy.
Right, the bonding
won't be as strong.
But I think that one of the
best analogies to think about
is so I'm coming in as a
liquid, so I'm now a liquid.
And here's my melting point for
the crystal, for the crystal.
But I went past it.
And I went past it,
and now, instead of--
I'm just going to
draw this out here.
There's the crystal.
Instead of going down to
become a crystal, suddenly
or super cooling, and
then becoming a crystal,
no, I super cool, and then
I just become a solid.
And then I just become a solid.
OK.
Now that-- this is a glass.
You know that it's a solid.
It's got the same
slope as the crystal.
The thermal expansion
of this thing
is the same as the
crystal or very similar.
So that's enough to tell
you this is a solid, right?
It should be a good indicator.
It should have been a nice
straight line just for now.
OK.
Yeah, but it didn't get--
those silicate blocks
didn't find the lattice.
They didn't find the lattice.
As you're cool-- here,
they've got all this freedom.
I mean, they're a
liquid, silicate, happy.
Maybe it's an even
higher temperature,
and the silicons are even
dissociated from the oxygen.
Let's just assume they're
in these silicate groups,
and they're floating around in a
liquid, and I start cooling it.
I think one of the best
analogies that I've heard
is that of musical chairs.
How many of you have
played musical chairs?
OK, you've got to
fix this tonight.
For those of you who
didn't raise your hand,
that's going on
the menu tonight,
because it's a really fun game.
With supercooled
water, of course.
You line up some chairs, and
you get around in a group
and you walk around
it as the music plays
and then the music stops and
everybody has to find a chair,
but there's a chair missing.
So you've got to go fast, or
you might not get to a chair.
Well, you see the silicate,
let's put it below here,
the silicates are you.
You are the silicates.
People equals silicate.
And the chair equal
lattice sites.
And now you can really feel it.
You can really feel it, because
the speed around the chairs.
How fast are you moving?
Right.
So the speed, well, if it's
speed around the chair,
OK, if that's fast, then
it's, you know, high mobility,
so let's see, speed around
chair, let's do this.
High mobility, maybe
you'd find, you know, find
lattice sites easier, or
faster, at least, but see,
if you have a high
1 over mobility--
by the way, that's
also viscosity,
if you have a high
1 over mobility.
So if you have a high
viscosity, [INAUDIBLE]..
High 1 over mobility, high
viscosity, then it's slow.
And that's how you have a
higher chance of forming glass.
So I'm going to talk about
what would make a glass form.
If you're just
walking around slowly,
like this, everyone
else is running,
but maybe you're
all walking slowly,
and now the music stops, and I'm
like, yeah, I'll take my time,
it's going to be hard to get
to the open lattice site.
I might just get stuck.
OK, so what else?
Well, OK, so how
about the arrangement?
So the chair
arrangement, that has
to do with the
crystal complexity.
And you can imagine that
if the chairs are arranged
in a straight line, and you're
going around the chairs,
and it's is kind
of an easy loop,
right, now I don't have
to concentrate too much
on where I'm going, and it's
kind of-- there's nothing
really blocking me,
I hope, but what
if those chairs were arranged
in a really complicated way.
So how hard is it to
get around these chairs?
How hard is it to find them?
How complex is the lattice?
And you can imagine
that it is higher.
So let's see.
More-- I'll just draw an arrow.
Higher would lead to glass.
OK, so it fits.
Higher complexity
of the lattice.
It might be harder
to find the lattice
sites in this musical chairs.
OK, one more, and
I'll put it here,
so that it's close
by, because I've
got no more room on that board.
The third one is how
fast you stop the music.
So this would be like
1, 2, and then 3.
How fast do we stop music?
OK.
So you can imagine if
I, you know, if I slowly
were playing musical chairs,
and I am walking around,
and I slowly fade
the music, all right,
well, then you got lots of time.
You got lots of time, but
what if I just stop it.
Now, everybody's scrambling.
So how fast do you stop the
music is the cooling rate.
It's how quickly you
cool this material.
It's how fast you
stop the music,
and you can imagine that
if it's faster, faster,
you are more likely
to form a glass.
You're more likely
to form a glass,
and so we go back
to our picture.
Well, maybe I'll draw one over
here, because I need more room,
and I don't want to
block what's there.
We go back to our picture and
here it is, drawn out for you.
You see that is--
OK, there is the
liquid line, coming in,
volume, OK, enthalpy,
visage, and we'll
keep thinking
about it as volume.
The liquid line comes in.
You're cooling it down.
There's the thermal expansion.
It's reducing,
reducing, and now I
get to the melting temperature,
and I become a crystal.
That's if it can
become a crystal,
but all of these
factors, now, matter.
The melting point of the crystal
is always the same number.
It's always the same number.
The melting point,
where the crystal melts,
because the crystal
is always the same.
Right.
Now, where that melts is
always the same temperature.
But notice now,
what have I done?
I've super cooled
the liquid down,
and on a, I've got a glass
that looks like this.
These are glasses.
And on b, I've got a glass
that looks like that.
Those are different.
And they have different
solidification temperatures.
And what do we call it?
We have a special
name for it, too.
We have a special name for it,
because it's not crystallizing.
Right, so if this is
the volume per mole,
and this is the temperature,
it's not crystallizing.
No.
What is it doing?
So that would be
the melting point.
It is turning into a glass,
and so we call this the glass
transition temperature.
It's a glass transition.
What that means is it
is still becoming--
gesundheit-- a solid, but
it's an amorphous solid.
It's not a crystal.
Why did it become
an amorphous solid?
Well, maybe I cooled
it really fast.
Or maybe it's a really
complex structure, right?
Or maybe the viscosity of
the material is very high,
and it just--
as I'm cooling it
down, it just couldn't
find the crystal lattice,
which is all the way down here.
And you can see from
this, that you know,
imagine I take
the extreme limit,
and I got my liquid
of my silicate groups,
and right as I get below here,
I'm like you're all frozen.
I'd literally-- I'd make a glass
right here, right up there,
all right.
So I can make glasses that
are different from each other.
And you can see that
the volume per mole
is increasing as
I go up, and you
can understand that, because
look, I took a glass.
I didn't let--
I took a liquid here.
This is the liquid.
I didn't let any of it
find crystals sites.
It's a liquid.
But I said, ha, you're frozen.
And it became frozen and stuck
at a high volume per mole.
Because it's totally
random and amorphous.
It's coming right from all
those random liquid degrees
of freedom are just frozen in.
Yeah, but now, I cool it slower.
Maybe that's what
happened here, right?
And I give it more time.
And I give it more time to find
some of those lattice sites,
and it finds some lattice sites,
but then it became a glass
at this temperature, the
glass transition temperature,
and everything
else is frozen in.
So if I label this, so let's
label it the same as there,
if I label a as this
one and b as this one,
and this is the crystal,
nope, the crystal
would have to go all
the way up to here.
There we go.
Right.
So if that's a, that's glass
a, and that's glass b, then
which one did I cool faster?
Well, I had to call
this one slower--
if all I changed between
them is cooling rates,
then this one is cooled faster.
So let me write it here.
a cooled slower than b.
Right.
Because I get-- and
that's this one here.
How fast did you stop the music?
Right.
It's the cooling rate.
OK, so this plot, this volume
versus temperature really
allows us to understand how
glass forms, or at least we can
plot, you know, what happened,
and then try to understand it.
And if it did get all
the way to the crystal,
then maybe it means that it's
not very viscous as a liquid,
it doesn't have a
complex lattice site,
and maybe it didn't even matter
how quickly-- oh, metals.
But that's why it's hard to
make glasses out of metals.
Because metals have an easy time
finding their lattice sites.
Metals as liquids typically
aren't very viscous.
And so even if you cool
it faster, it's got time.
The musical chairs
of metals is easy.
It's an easy game.
That's why the silicates
never played musical chairs
with metals.
But I can still
do it, and the way
you make a glass out
of a metal, the way
you make a metallic glass,
which is a really cool material
is you freeze it really quickly.
You will lower the temperature
as quickly as you can,
really, really fast, and
you freeze in the disorder,
and you make a metallic glass.
OK, so those are the two curves
I just talked about there.
That's the glass curve.
This would be the crystal curve.
OK, two different
cooling rates on here.
OK, now, here's a
picture of float glass.
This is the kind of glass--
we're going to move from
understanding what glass is
and understanding in terms of
this temperature versus volume
plot and amorphous
solids, and we're
going to move
towards understanding
how to modify it,
how to control it,
because we do a lot of that.
Here's an example
of a factor right--
I like this.
This is flow glass.
So this is like when you
buy, you know, your windows,
or you know, a
lot of times, when
you need a very clear,
beautiful piece of glass,
you go up to very
high temperatures.
All right, so you're
taking those silicates.
You make them into a liquid.
Here he is, measuring
the temperature.
I don't know what he's
doing actually, whatever.
Oh and this isn't
showing up very well.
And there's no
volume, so double--
OK, there it is.
So there's the liquid glass.
Why is it called float glass?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- The process is monitored
continuously by technicians
to ensure quality.
But because it floats on
top of another liquid.
That's how you get the glass
because so incredibly smooth.
- And ensure uniformity--
And there it is coming out.
There's a nice wide piece
of glass coming out,
and what he says at the end of
this, there it is coming out.
[END PLAYBACK]
They can do kilometers
and kilometers
per day of this float glass.
You float it over molten tin.
The tin acts like this
really nice smooth surface
that you put the
glass on top of.
So one liquid on top of
another makes a very nice
smooth interface.
And what he talks about, which
is what I wanted to capture,
is how important
that cooling is.
So the line has to go
in a very particular way
after it comes out,
as you cool it,
and because it's all
about the cooling.
As you come all the way back
down to here, room temperature,
right, or as I--
maybe as I went through
this transition,
what's happening inside?
Am I creating a lot of stress?
We just learned about stress.
Right, or is it going
to cool in a nice way?
Are there going to
be cracks that form?
So that is one of the
most important processing
parameters.
What we'll learn next week is
that chemistry is also a really
important pressing parameter.
And that's why you have
such good phone screens.
Actually, you don't really,
because they always break,
but they would break even more
if it weren't for chemistry.
OK, but certainly cooling
speed is really important.
So let's go to the--
OK, now how--
OK, if you look
at glass, remember
I said that it's got order or no
order, crystalline, amorphous,
crystalline, amorphous.
How do you tell
which one you have?
Who can tell me?
You just learned about it.
What do you do to see if
something is a crystal
and which crystal it is?
You shine x-rays on it.
You go to your x-ray source,
and you just shine it on,
and you measure
where it bounces off.
But see-- so if you did that,
so if you look in the circle,
they look the same.
They look the same.
That's crystalline.
That's quartz.
This is glass.
Quartz, glass,
crystalline, amorphous.
Right, but if you go to the long
range order, there isn't any.
So if I shine x-rays, these are
two different types of solids.
Think about it like DCC
FCC, but they're not.
They're more complicated
of quartz or of silicates.
This is what glass
would look like.
Look at that.
There's still like a little
bit of a peak there, but not
really, right, because this
is from the short range order,
but here's the important
part, which is where--
you can still, even
though it's not
that everything is where
you think it is, right,
because it in a crystal, you
know everything's BCC or FCC.
Every lattice is the same.
You know you can
count on it for 10
to the 20 second repetitions.
Here you can't.
You can still control
the properties.
So the properties can
be highly engineered.
And here's an example.
So these are different
types of glass.
This is a glass cup, and
this is a glass bottle.
And you might think,
it's just glass.
No.
It's not just glass.
It's very complicated mixtures
of silica with other things.
Notice, it's got soda.
This is-- like I said,
this is not soda,
but it comes from soda, so
it's called soda, sodium
oxide in Na2O.
Lime CaO, magnesia, alumina.
All the glass-- you know, unless
you pay a whole lot of money
for something made of quartz,
almost all the glass you buy
has this kind of stuff in it.
In fact, 90% of all glass
is called soda glass,
because it's got--
that's this one here.
That's this cup, because
it's got sodium oxide in it.
And the question is why.
Why do we put these
things in glass?
Why did we used to
put lead in glass?
In fact, the history is pretty--
goes back thousands of years.
And I found this.
If you go to ancient
Rome, they made glass,
and you can look at what
they made glass out of.
They had a little
bit less silica.
But they mixed all
sorts of things in.
They did not have
3091 back then,
so they didn't really
know why this was doing
something useful, but it was.
Now we mix all these oxides,
remember I wrote some of them
up here, lime, soda.
We mix those in, and we mix
all sorts of other things in,
but now we know why.
And the reason why is
all about the chemistry,
and it all goes back to
this picture right here.
It all goes back to exactly this
Lewis structure that I started
with, which is not on the--
stop it.
No.
It's stuck here.
Maybe it's here.
Yes.
That made me happy.
This all goes back
to the chemistry.
If I deliver, if I deliver
into this system something that
gives me charged oxygens,
something that provides
a little bit of O
minus or O2 minus,
then I could cut this bond back.
I can cut this all the way
back to the original silicate,
sort of.
If I had an oxygen
with charge on it,
I can go from here back to
where I started, right there,
at least for that bond, right?
And so what every single one
of these things has in common
is that it can provide
into the system
a charged oxygen, a
charged oxygen atom.
If this dissociates, it gives
we Ca2 plus and O2 minus.
If this dissociates, it gives me
two Na pluses and an O2 minus.
Oh, a pattern is forming
here, O2 minus, O2 minus,
O2 minus all the way down.
So these modifiers, these things
that we use to engineer glass,
they give me the O2 minus,
and that is the knife
that I use to cut this
glass apart and modify
its properties, and
it's where we're
going to pick up on Wednesday.
But because it's a Friday, I
want to throw t-shirts out.
We'll do more next week.
Have a really good
holiday weekend.